we've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p here's a good question.
Do I just tell the audience what I think on
this show or do I calculate what I say?
Uh, based on who I perceive the audience to
be?
Take a listen.
Hi David.
My name is Jacob.
I standard years.
I'm a third year law students in, uh, Colorado.
My question for you is very simple.
Do you feel as a talk show kind of host, especially
more leaning to the left that you are able
to give your firm and unbiased opinion, um,
all the time?
Or do you feel that sometimes you have to
tell the audience kind of what they want to
hear?
Um, I guess it's more of like an integrity
question.
Do you feel that you are able to be yourself
without telling Yachty's what you think they
want to hear?
Are you able to say what you want and have
the risk of having your audience kind of lash
back out and have, yeah.
Listen, I, uh, do simply tell it the way I
see it and it sometimes causes conflicts even
within my core audience and I do not calculate
what I think the audience wants to hear, number
one, because I think it would be the wrong
thing to do.
I just want to do the show the way I want
to do it.
And that includes just giving my views.
I don't calculate what is going to give me
the, the sort of best outcome in terms of
how the audience will react.
And then from a practical standpoint, nobody
is going to be pleased.
Not you will never please everyone no matter
what position you take.
So I made the decision long ago.
I'll just tell it the way I see it, period.
And you can disagree with me.
Um, you can say I'm a bad person for what
I believe, but I'm telling you what I believe
and I will continue to do that.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Become a member or a patron
by signing up at David pakman.com/membership
or patrion.com/david Pakman show, which will
give you instant access to the bone.